[Music]
yeah
yeah
I
[Music]
warning
occasionally those warnings and no one
cares
hello everyone
law and order are the building blocks to
the American dream but if anarchy
prevails this dream comes comes
crumbling down an RP and our streets is
unacceptable and anger is not enough you
have a president committed to action the
DOJ has arrested over 100 a Nargis for
rioting and destruction of federal
property the DOJ has also charged four
men in federal court for attempting to
tear down the statue of Andrew Jackson
in Lafayette Square
the FBI has over 200 open domestic
terrorism investigations ongoing AG Barr
has created a task force on violent
anti-government extremists led by the US
Attorney's Office in New Jersey and the
US Attorney's Office in northern Texas
with 200 trump appointed judges
confirmed the rule of law will be upheld
Democrats at all level at all levels
federal state and local have done
nothing Senate Democrats blocked
bipartisan police reform Minnesota's
Democrat governor failed to urgently
deploy the National Guard it took
President Trump for that to eventually
happen his suggestion and the ultimate
Descendants into chaos
there in Minneapolis three Democrat
Minneapolis Council members voted to
abolish the police while they themselves
were getting a private security detail
that's quite rich Democrat mayor of
Seattle called
the choc zone the autonomous zone the
Summer of Love it is anything but that
with one dead multiple shootings and
desperate pleas for help unanswered by
business owners and others eleven people
were shot in 12 hours this weekend in
the Democrat run New York City and 61
people were shot in Democrat run Chicago
and 15 fatally killed a Democrat State a
Democrat city president Trump stands
against defunding our brave police
officers caving to mob rule
and canceled culture which seeks to
erase our history let's be clear the
rampant destruction of statues is not a
part of any ideology but this anarchy is
aided by failed Democrat leadership and
as president Trump has tweeted these
statues quote are great works of art but
all represent our history and heritage
both the good and the bad it is
important for us to understand and
remember even in turbulent and difficult
times and to learn from them so let's
stand for law and order for peace in our
streets and against anarchy this is
president Trump's vision for the future
and with that I'll take questions Chris
Thank You Kaylee I know you said that
President Crump was never briefed on
these reports about the Russian counties
and whatnot but can you say that he was
briefed today he'll say this that the
u.s. receives thousands of reports a day
on intelligence and they're subject to
strict scrutiny while the White House
does not routinely comment on alleged
intelligence or internal deliberations
the CIA director NSA national security
adviser and the chief of staff can all
confirm neither the president nor the
Vice President were briefed on the
alleged French Russian bouncy
intelligence has he been since brief
since all of these replies came out so
let me back up and say this that there
is no consensus within the intelligence
community on these allegations and and
in effect there are dissenting opinions
from some in the intelligence community
with regards to the veracity of what's
being reported and the veracity of the
underlying allegations continue to be
evaluated and one more question if I
could this upset that this intelligence
was reportedly shared with the British
government but not him I have no further
comment on that other than to just point
you back to the two assertions that I
made previously no as I noted there was
not a consensus among the intelligence
community and in fact there were
dissenting opinions within the
intelligence community and it would not
be elevated to the president until it
was verified the truncated overnight
Intel just spoke to me what specifically
does that mean
him did that person he's the president
for briefing in that company so I know
are there details on the president's
private correspondence tell us who's
coming to the White House today and he
could have bleep those lawmakers so what
I can tell you about that is that last
night the chief of staff mark meadows
called both Senator McConnell and
congressman Hoyer and breat and said
that he would be briefing eight members
from the Committees of jurisdiction so
there was a bipartisan invitation
extended but no further details other
than everything gonna happen today Haley
yes it was ongoing at the time when I
came out here at least it started I
think 30 minutes prior to me coming out
here they're gonna come to the white
just eyes really be clear about what
that members of Congress have coming to
the White House yes
Kaitlyn okay I have two questions one
event concerning that there was even a
hint of credibility to this report that
the Russians were offering to a Taliban
linked militants to kill American troops
and the president was not told about it
husband security adviser or anyone
explained why they didn't think it
roasts below that the commander in chief
should find out about it so intelligence
is verified before it reaches the
President of the United States and in
this case it was not verified
I wouldn't note this though when the
president there's no stronger advocate
for our servicemen and women then
President Trump he never hesitates to
act when there is a threat to our
servicemen and women for example in
Syria and 2018 when dozens dozens of
Russian mercenaries were killed and
retaliatory defensive us-led strikes so
when our adversaries have directly
targeted us or coalition partners the
president has not hesitated to act but
this was not briefed up to the president
because it was not in fact verified I
understand has to be verified but not
everything in his daily briefing during
the presidential Daily Brief that's the
written document is airtight Jane let
the president know about what they are
hearing that's why it's intelligence so
why would that not have been something
versatile of the National Security
Council in the intelligence community
constantly evaluate intelligence reports
and they brief the president has
necessary okay so my other question is
if this does be borne out or the
President believes that it is true
what is he going to do to hold Russia
accountable and is he still going to
invite Blatter Putin to the g7 g8 I
won't speculate on whether this
intelligence is verified or not verified
and I won't get ahead of the President
on further actions but I would just
point out that no one's I'm not
disputing no I'm not true no one there
are dissenting opinions within the
intelligence community and I can confirm
it with you right now that there is no
consensus within the intelligence
community on these allegations and
further I would just point out it won't
get a head of the President on actions
but with regard to Russia this president
has been extremely strong on Russia
imposing sanctions on hundreds of
Russian individuals expelling dozens of
diplomats closing two russian consulates
withdrawing from an INF treaty and
several other actions in the
intelligence community
I have no further no further
notifications for you other than to tell
you there's no consensus and there are
dissenting opinions from some with
anything that is free you don't think
this report is true I'm telling you this
that there is no consensus in the
intelligence community and that the
dissenting opinions from some in the
intelligence community exists darling
thank you Kelly
I wanted to go back to the president
yesterday retweet other people's tweets
and videos without we did not hear that
particular phrase when he tweeted out
the video and he did and he did not hear
that particular phrase also given your
overly do you have any comment on this
decision from Mississippi to make and
it's commendable that they took this
action in a law firm lawful manner and
took the appropriate steps rather than
trying to tear down statues and
monuments
on another issue does the president have
a specific message for Moscow given
these reports a specific message for
Moscow no because he has not been
briefed on the matter as I noted there's
no consensus among the intelligence
community and there are in fact
dissenting opinions on a separate issue
Jacksonville Florida today apparently is
issuing a mask order that of course is
where the at least part of the RNC will
be held later this summer has the
president's thinking about wearing a
mask changed at all
given that order and given the increased
coronavirus cases in Texas Florida
Arizona and elsewhere
so I talked to the president before
coming out here he it's his choice to
wear a mask it's the personal choice of
any individual as to whether to wear a
mask or not he encourages people to make
whatever decision is best for their
safety but he did say to me he has no
problem with masks and to do whatever
your local jurisdiction requests of you
yes thank you like there have been
reports that some American service
members actually were killed as a result
of this question tell me what
information you look again i pointing
you back to the fact that there's no
consensus within the intelligence
community and i would also note that for
those of you that are always taking the
new york times at their word they
erroneously reported that the president
was briefed on this he was not briefed
on this and neither was the vice
president so before i'm buying into
full-fledged and narrative from the new
york times that falsely stated something
about the president that you would wait
for the facts to come out and note once
again there's no consensus in the Intel
community and in fact their dissenting
opinions from some within it you say
that he wasn't does that mean it wasn't
in the PDB either he was not personally
briefed on the matter that is all I can
share with you today it's that both the
CIA director the national security
adviser and the chief of staff can all
confirm neither the President or the
vice president was briefed okay
secretaries are said that the window is
closing this is
cases are on the rise this is a very
serious time obviously the vice
president held held a briefing on Friday
um what is the president's message to
the American people and why aren't we
seeing him publicly talk to the public
encourage them to do things to stay safe
I would note that there is a whole
coronavirus task force briefing on
Friday where all of these questions that
the American public had were addressed
we're encouraged to see that fatalities
are coming down that this Sunday I
believe we had our lowest fatality rate
since I believe was March 22nd so late
March what that signals to us is we're
catching people and the communities the
people who are being infected tend to be
those as vice president Pence has noted
half of those testing positive are under
the age of 35 this means we're catching
people in their communities we're aware
that there are embers that need to be
put out but these signs of decreasing
fatality increased in enhanced
therapeutics that we've identified four
of them dexamethasone convalescent
plasma and REM death-sphere and one
other that they are working from
desapear in particular reduces hospital
time by a third so these things make us
uniquely equipped to handle the increase
in cases that we've seen there's a
national conversation going on right now
about the proper place of symbols of the
Confederacy statues memorials names and
the president has repeatedly inserted
himself into this debate I think a lot
of people trying to understand what his
view of memorializing the Confederacy is
in a proper place of the Confederate
flag so a couple questions what does he
believe this president Trump believed
that it was a good thing that the South
lost the Civil War and then too is he
interested in following and banning the
absolutely absurd he's proud of the
United States of America second with
regard to our statues Americans oppose
tearing down our statues there's a
Harvard Harris poll released just last
week that shows 60% of respondents
said the statue should remain and 71
percent said local governments should
block groups from physically destroying
the statues so he stands on the side of
preserving our history actually about
the Confederate flag at his rallies what
he's interested in banning that would be
a question for his campaign but look
this president's focused on taking
action on fixing problems it's why he
had his executive order just a few weeks
ago to keep our streets safe and secure
that's where his focus lies and I think
that those who are tearing down statues
they do appear to have no ideology when
there's tearing down statues and
defacing statues of Matthias Baldwin and
abolitionists Hans Christian Hague who
died fighting for the Union Army during
the Civil War memorial for
african-american soldiers who fought in
the Civil War was damaged in Boston and
a monument fallen police officers was
vandalized in Sacramento this is
unacceptable it's why the president took
strong action it's why as an executive
order saying those tearing down statues
will be punished to the fullest extent
of the law it's why four people will
charge he will not stand for lawlessness
and chaos he stands with the 71% of
Americans who say there is no place for
tearing down statues anarchists are
doing across the nation and secondly
curiously give us a little info on how
the base or negotiations are going you
get a sense that Congress is open to
work on this I don't have any updates
for you on face for more infrastructure
but the president has mentioned on for
the last three years he's very keen on
Democrats coming to the table and
working with us on infrastructure he's
keen on in a phase for seeing a payroll
tax holiday which helps low wage workers
and those who need it most
these are real effective measures that
could help the American people but the
onus is really on Democrats to come to
the negotiating table this is going to
be different than
yeah I won't get ahead of the President
or those negotiations Stephen thank you
I had two questions first of statues
covered pretty closely the Trump
inauguration rioting trials and boots
all and essentially jury nullification
and no one was convicted and I was
wondering you pressing Trump is
concerned about the possibility that the
same will happen with the people who
were charged before or trying to topple
the deaf student statute particularly on
this personal roll look that that'll be
a decision for the courts to make and
for juries to make but the president is
very keen on seeing these actions
brought to justice because tearing down
American monuments and defacing federal
property and defacing the Lincoln
Memorial are not things the American
public want to see as noted with that
71% poll my second question is over the
weekend President Trump retweeted a
contrast of this presidency and
President Obama's and there was a chart
of the different things that President
Obama did and President Trump did and
one of the differences was President
Obama approving the extradition
extrajudicial killings of Americans
overseas there was a little bit of
confusion earlier President Ramos
presidency about his are you able to
verify whether he opposes that look I
would just say this
the president will always point to the
difference between his record and that
of President Obama which is what he was
getting at with his tweets you had on
one hand in the obama-biden presidency
the weakest economic recovery since
World War two with President Trump we
got to the hottest economy in modern
history with President Trump you have
saw Isis defeated with Vice President
Joe Biden and President Obama the
so-called JV team of Isis became the
varsity team in over an two separate
countries so the president will always
draw a contrast with President Obama and
those are just two of the many and he
was drawing contrast in that play Thanks
questions October 19 first off friend
disappear we found out today the pricing
of it going forward for roughly a
five-day trial $2,300 for government
back programs $3,100 in the commercial
marketplace does the White House this
president trial
approve of that pricing of that price
point considering there's been some
criticism as to whether or not that's
too high so like that's a really good
important and substantive question that
I think deserves a good answer to and
first the wholesale acquisition costs or
the federal supply schedule is about
thirty two hundred four course of
randint REM to severe but ROM disappears
an inpatient drugs done by infusion and
because it is an inpatient drug the
patient would be very unlikely to see
the cost of the drug and pay the cost of
the drug because the way that hospitals
get reimbursed for inpatient drugs is
that they are paid flat fees for
admission I mean as secretary A's are
explained to me this means in laymen
terms that hospitals have to eat the
cost of treatment use but if they buy
room desapear for let's say thirty two
hundred dollars which is the wholesale
acquisition cost and that REM disappear
drug saves that patient time in the
hospital they only spend a third of the
time in the hospital as a patient
without Rinda severe that would mean
that the hospitals are actually
profiting because they're getting the
patient out early so that some it
basically all comes down to saying that
the patient will not see that cost and
then secondly just picking up where what
Jeff had asked about mass he said the
president has no problem with masks and
that individuals should do whatever
their local jurisdiction requests
however that HHS secretary Alex days are
said this weekend quote we've got a
practice social distancing we've got to
use face coverings when we can't
practice social distancing so if
individuals are going into an area and
social distancing cannot be practiced
should they listen to the local
jurisdiction in which face masks
might not necessarily be mandated or
should they listen to the HHS secretary
who says wear a face mask so the CDC
guidelines are they're recommended but
not required and we the president would
encourage everyone to follow the orders
of their local jurisdiction and CDC
guidelines I just wanna be clear there
congressional leaders were being briefed
on the situation
is still an instruction book this has
been asked and answered the president is
briefs on verified intelligence how does
he know if he hasn't been certain the
president has briefed on verified
intelligence and again I would just
point you back to the absolutely
irresponsible decision of the New York
Times to falsely report that he was
briefed on something that he in fact was
not briefed on and I really think that
it's time for the New York Times to step
back and ask themselves why they've been
wrong so wrong so often the New York
Times falsely claimed Paul Manafort
asked for polling data to be passed
along to Oleg Oleg Deripaska before
having to issue a correction in June of
2017 the New York Times falsely wrote
all 17 Intel agencies had agreed on
Russian interference for not before
having to issue a correction that it was
only for agencies in 2017 February of
that year New York Times published a
story claiming Trump campaign aides had
repeated contacts with Russian
intelligence which even James Comey has
said was almost entirely wrong New York
Times New York Times published a column
in March of 2019 by a former times
executive editor that asserted the Trump
campaign in Russia had an overarching
deal that the quit of help in the
campaign against Hillary for the quo of
a new pro-russian foreign policy that's
what we call the Russia hoax which was
investigated for three years with
taxpayer dollars before ultimately
getting an exoneration and the Moller
reported is inexcusable
the failed Russia reporting of the New
York Times and I think it's time that
the New York Times and also the
Washington Post hand back their
Pulitzers condemned white power why
haven't you condemned that tweet